you vaccinate millions of people it's
inevitable that you have
rare or serious incidences
of illnesses that occur after
vaccination
and our role at the ema is to
evaluate these to make sure that any
suspected adverse reactions are
rapidly investigated so we can figure
out
is this a real side effect to the
vaccine or is it a coincidence
now to do this we have mobilized our
pharmacovisions and risk assessment
committee which is a safety committee
made up of mainly from experts from the
national competence authorities from
across the eu
but we also have patient representatives
and healthcare
professional representatives on this
committee and in this case we've also
pulled in experts
from some of our international partners
to help us with the evaluation
and we've put in experts who have
expertise in uh thromboembolic events
um events
involving uh club plots some with very
unusual
features such as low number of platelets
have occurred
in a very small number of people who
have received the vaccine
and these reports have been received
through eudra vigilance
the european database for suspected as
adverse drug reaction reports but of
course we know that many people many
thousands of people develop blood clots
annually in the eu for many different
reasons
so what we call on our expert committee
to do is to establish whether there
might be a causal relationship
between the vaccinations and these
events in other words whether the
vaccines
might have caused the adverse events
that occurred or whether the events are
likely to be due to other causes
so this requires a very rigorous
analysis of
all the data related to trombonic events
and the experts look in great detail at
all the available data
but also at the clinical circumstances
surrounding the specific cases
to determine whether the vaccine might
have contributed
or it's likely to have been due to other
other causes
now i last week our expert committee met
several times on this issue but in the
meantime
the interest in these events has
actually stimulated
additional reporting so we're evaluating
each of the incidences on a case-by-case
event
so our experts are actually meeting
again today
so having having met most of last week
they have
they we have um pulled together an ad
hoc meeting
again today to help us evaluate these
cases
with all the surrounding information
that
the member states will have
the experts will then carry on their
assessment and they again
will meet on thursday to come to a
conclusion
on the full information that has been
gathered
and to advise us as to whether there are
any further actions that need to be
taken and we will inform the public of
the outcome
immediately after this meeting i want to
stress
that our experts are working tirelessly
to carry out this as
this assessment as quickly as possible
but it
needs a scientific evaluation we need to
have the facts
first we cannot come to a conclusion
until we've done a
thorough scientific analysis and we owe
it to the european citizens to
deliver this clear and science-based
response so i want to also stress that
at present
there is no indication that vaccination
has caused these conditions
they have not come up in the clinical
trials and they're not listed as known
or
expected side events with this vaccine
in clinical trials both the vaccinated
people and the people who receive the
placebo
have shown small some very small numbers
of blood clot developments
we don't the number of thromboembolic
events
overall in the vaccinated people seems
not to be higher than that seen
in the general population
i don't need to remind you all here
today that the covet 19 pandemic is a
global crisis with devastating
health social and economic impact and it
continues to be a major burden on eu
health
health systems vaccines for covet 19
help to protect individuals from
becoming ill
especially health care professionals and
vulnerable populations such as older
people and those with chronic diseases
and this is a very important
consideration in our assessment of the
benefit risks
so while the investigation is ongoing we
are
currently we are still firmly convinced
that the benefits of the astrophysenica
vaccine in preventing covert 19
with its associated risk of
hospitalization and death
outweigh the risk of these side effects
in the meantime
anyone who has received the vaccine and
has any concerns
should contact their appropriate
healthcare professional
it's important that people who suspect
that they have a side effect
after vaccination report this to the
national medicines regulator or to a
healthcare professional
who can help them to do so
thousands of people are dying across the
eu
every day we have authorized four
highly effective covet vaccines that can
protect
against severe covet disease
these are very rare trombone events
or blood clots we need to evaluate these
very very carefully the ad hoc to me at
the ad hoc meeting today we will have a
further update
but as i said it's thursday when we
expect the
evaluation to conclude ema
is taking this situation very very
seriously and we will continue to make
sure that the european population is
informed about the outcome
of ongoing analysis
of this assessment thank you very much
thank you very much emir i will now open
the floor
for questions uh james crisp
the floor is yours
thank you stefan i hope you can hear me
there have been reports
in the u.s of similar cases of blood
clots linked to the fisa and moderna
vaccines
i'd like to ask miss cook please if she
has
had any similar reports in the eu and if
it's something that the ema
is looking into thank you
thank you emir
please press speak
yes thank you very much for the question
and it's it's indeed
very relevant in fact
we are evaluating um we are looking at
at adverse events associated with all
vaccines
at the moment the current focus because
of the
um reported incident in europe is on the
astrazeneca
but we have looked at the background
rates for all
all the vaccines currently in
circulation
and it looks like there are similar
numbers uh coming in across the world
but that is something that will have to
be evaluated
uh by um our committee
thank you very much thank you very much
oliver grimm please
hello hi oliver come with me hello
oliver clinton with the austrian
newspaper depressor
a question on a decision the us
fda took on the 25th of february
concerning
uh the the suggested temperature for
storage and transport of the biotech
pfizer vaccine does the ema already have
a plan for when it's going to
you know find any any decision on this
matter give a
recommendation to the member states
whether this vaccine really has to be
stored and transported
at minus 70 degrees celsius or could be
also handled
at higher temperatures thank you
emer yeah thank you very much and of
course the
um the logistics of rolling out some of
these vaccines is very important
for making sure that they reach
all populations so we are also looking
at
any new information on the storage
conditions associated with the vaccine
we have we have looked at
the in-use storage of the pfizer
biontech vaccine and
we will be coming out with an evaluation
on this
very shortly thank you
thank you frank jordans
you have to switch on your microphone
frank
hello i hope you can hear me now frank
jordan's from ap
that's good so um
some details have been coming out about
the cases
that occurred in germany including that
there were
three deaths among the um seven
csvt cases and i'm wondering if you have
any further
information about those and other cases
across the european union that you can
share with us at this time
yes thank you very much yes indeed we
are receiving uh
cases and more details more details of
the circumstances of those cases
effectively as we speak and uh what
we're
um understanding is that there may be
some uh they they may be associated with
some sub populations or there may indeed
be
some subpopulations of the overall
thromboembolic events but i'm not in a
position to comment on the particular
cases that have come through
from germany other than to say that
these are being discussed
at the pharmaco vigilance and risk
assessment committee
donato mancini go ahead
hi can you hear me we hear you going i
hear you go ahead and hi good afternoon
thanks for taking my question
um is there any indication that the
series of very adverse events
especially the most serious ones
are related in any way to specific
batches and
does the batch hypothesis form part of
the probe that is currently underway
thank you emir please inner peace
yes uh thank you very much and this is a
very important point um
because originally i think many of you
will be aware that
um but some specific batches were
suspected as being linked to um
these side events um so
we have actually mobilized our
biological
working party to look carefully into
the possibility or plausibility of any
events
linked to specific batches or in fact
any differences in manufacturing
in any way that might lead to some
disparities
across batches so that's part of the
investigation
thank you so that's emma
cook they're the head of regulation at
the european medicine agency um
let's bring in our europe correspondent
michelle clifford who was listening
into that as well um and michelle the
ema they're saying that they they see no
indication
that the astrazeneca jab is the cause of
those reported blood clots but they are
investigating it
yeah i think very much much this was a
message of uh
reassurance to people reassurance that
they have found
no causal link between uh the reported
cases of blood clots and the astrazeneca
vaccine but also reassurance that they
feel
strongly that the benefits of taking the
vaccine
still outweigh the risks because there
are real problems
in terms of the pr of the astrozenica
vaccine that
go back uh way before these problems
related into
reported uh blood clots germany and
france for example
decided not to give the astrazeneca
vaccine to the elderly that laid many
people
in the wider populations to ask why i
was in germany
and france in the last couple of weeks
and people were telling me that they
were trying to ask for
the fisa vaccine or another vaccine
because uh they had
concerns so there is that uh real worry
and of course now
the likes of germany and france have
followed other countries in
terms of suspending uh the vaccine roll
out that's a real problem because the eu
already had
an intense shortage of vaccinations so
not having this particular vaccine there
is going to cause
real problems of course eu leaders would
never want their legacy to be that they
gave
vaccinations that weren't safe to the
populations
of their country so people like
president macron of france
were saying they wanted to wait until
the ema had carried out the review
that's taking place
uh this week and they will be reassured
what by what e mccook said in the last
um 20 minutes or so that they still
believe the benefits
outweigh the risks that they haven't
found a causal link between the blood
clots
and the vaccination she said that
they've called in experts
from all over to look at the specific
cases and they are going to be analyzing
the specific specific cases case
by case we're expecting some sort of
announcement from the european medicines
agency on thursday to say what
next steps may be needed we're also
expecting later today
kimberly an announcement from the world
health organization
um in terms of the astrazeneca vaccine
it too has said that the rollout the
vaccination program
doesn't need to be stopped okay michelle
thank you
now the duke of edinburgh has this
afternoon thanked the medical staff who
treated him after he was discharged from
king edward vii hospital
to return to windsor castle prince
philip was first